VAC.
If you’ve watched enough CS:GO, no doubt,
you’ve encountered this three-letter acronym
before.
You’ve probably seen it spammed in Twitch
chat after a nutty jump-shot, a crazy flick,
or just an insane one-tap.
I’m Colin from theScore esports, and today
we’re talking about the best VAC-worthy
shots in CS:GO.
(Casting)
VAC stands for Valve Anti-Cheat.
It’s an automated system brought in
to help weed out those unscrupulous characters
who just can’t seem to play the game fair.
If you do get hit with a VAC ban, it is permanent,
and it is non-negotiable.
Now, to be clear guys, we are NOT talking
about actual VAC banned players or plays in
this video.
And we’re not accusing any of the pros featured
of cheating, we’re simply showing you plays
so good, timing so precise, and gamesense
so on-point, it looks like they could be.
Now, let’s get things started with some
unreal
VAC-worthy wallbangs.
(Casting)
Okay guys, some of the mechanically gifted
players in our next section straight up look
like aimbots out there.
They’re racking up kills through smokes,
through flashes, and hitting flick shots that
make you want to spam VAC in chat .
(Casting)
Being on the receiving end of a jumping shot
or a runboost feels SO BAD.
Just ask the victims of our next set of plays.
(Casting)
Alright guys that’s it for our collection of VAC-worthy
plays.
Now if you’ve got a favorite play that
you think deserves a VAC-ation, and we missed
it, hit me up in the comment section and I
will see you next week.